comment est apparu la vie sur Terre et à
quoi pourrait ressembler des formes de
vie extraterrestres ailleurs que sur
terre ce sont des questions absolument
fascinantes et aujourd'hui je vais vous
raconter comment j'ai eu la chance de
réaliser depuis deux ans un travail de
recherche sur le sujet c'est quelque
chose que j'ai fait en collaboration
avec Stuart qui est Astro biologiste à
l'université Caltech en Californie et
notre travail vient enfin d'être publié
dans un article scientifique qu'on a
écrit ensemble alors ça peut vous
paraître un peu surprenant que je fasse
de la recherche sur un sujet de ce genre
vous le savez peut-être ma spécialité
d'origine c'est plutôt la physique
fondamentale par les origines de la vie
mais vous allez voir que si j'en suis
arrivé là et bien c'est grâce à cette
chaîne Youtube tout a commencé il y a
environ deux ans avec une de mes vidéos
qui portaient sur la définition de ce
qu'est la vie pour préparer la vidéo
j'avais contacté sur darklet au sujet de
son propre travail de recherche et je
vais vous raconter comment de façon
totalement inattendue il m'a finalement
proposé de travailler avec lui pour
qu'on essaye ensemble de pousser plus
loin la recherche sur le sujet voici
l'histoire de cette collaboration au
départ la vidéo que je réalisais portait
sur la question de la définition de la
vie quels sont les critères qui nous
permettent de dire qu'un truc est vivant
et qu'un autre ne l'est pas et surtout
est-ce qu'on pourrait formuler cette
définition mais sans faire référence à
la vie telle qu'on la connaît
actuellement sur terre c'est à dire
définir le vivant mais sans parler de
protéines d'ADN ou de membranes
cellulaire c'est une question importante
pour imaginer à quoi pourrait ressembler
des formes de vie extraterrestres pas
forcément basées sur les mêmes
ingrédients que nous mais c'est
également utile pour comprendre comment
la vie sur Terre a pu apparaître sous
des formes intermédiaires encore plus
simple que celle qu'on peut imaginer
aujourd'hui dans ma vidéo il y a deux
ans je discutais notamment le travail de
Stuart barklet et Michael Wong qui
ensemble avait proposé quatre critères
pour définir la vie au sens large et
pour la distinguer de la vie sur terre
telle qu’on la connaît life en anglais
ils avaient décidé d'appeler ça à loyf
avec un Y
selon leur définition les quatre
critères pour définir la loyf la vie au
sens large était structure dissipative
autocattalise homéostasie et
apprentissage alors si ça vous intéresse
je vous renvoie à ma vidéo complète sur
le sujet mais je résume rapidement ce
que ça veut dire une structure
dissipative c'est un système qui se
maintient dans un certain état ordonné
en consommant de l'énergie
l'autocatisme c'est en gros l'idée de
pouvoir se reproduire et s'étendre
l'homéostasie c'est la capacité à se
maintenir en équilibre malgré des
perturbations extérieures et enfin
l'apprentissage c'est l'idée assez
générale de pouvoir enregistrer des
informations sur son environnement et de
les exploiter pour améliorer ses chances
de survie l'évolution darwinienne peut
rentrer dans cette catégorie mais ça
n'est pas la seule possibilité
la vie sur terre telle qu'on la connaît
satisfait évidemment ces quatre critères
mais barklet et Wong ont proposé que ces
critères soient une caractérisation
suffisamment générale pour permettre de
qualifier d'autres formes de vie très
différentes de la nôtre par exemple
celle qui pourrait exister ailleurs que
sur terre peut-être sans être basé sur
l'eau ou le carbone mais aussi pour
essayer d'identifier des étapes
intermédiaires qui ont pu conduire à la
vie sur terre telle qu'on la connaît
est-ce qu'une forme de vie primitive a
pu émerger sans ADN et ARN comme une
sorte de chaînon manquant encore plus
simple dans ma vidéo je présentais donc
en détail ces quatre critères ainsi que
des exemples de plusieurs systèmes a
priori non-vivants mais satisfaisant 1 2
ou 3 de ces critères et je parlais
notamment beaucoup d'un travail de Stord
barklet sur des simulations de système
chimiques simples qui arrivait à
reproduire trois des quatre piliers de
la loyf
ces simulations montraient que le
système chimique en question était une
structure dissipative capable d'auto
catalyse et d'homéostasie les trois
premiers critères de la loïf mais pas le
quatrième celui de l'apprentissage
je trouvais ces simulations fascinantes
et j'avais donc préalablement écrit à
Stuart pour voir si il pouvait m'envoyer
ses vidéos de simulation et motorisées à
les montrer dans la vidéo et Stuart m'a
répondu très sympathiquement qu'il était
OK et m'a envoyé les fichiers de ses
vidéos sauf qu'entre temps je m'étais
amusé à essayer de les reproduire
moi-même avec des techniques
algorithmiques que j'avais étudiées dans
le cadre de mon travail et ça a marché
hyper bien j'avais des simulations sur
GPU super détaillées et très rapide et à
la fin dans mon épisode j'ai finalement
utilisé les images de mes propres
simulations mais j'ai quand même envoyé
les vidéos à squard pour lui montrer et
il a trouvé les simulations super
meilleurs que les siennes et il m'a donc
que proposer de travailler avec lui pour
essayer de pousser le travail de
recherche encore plus loin
son idée c'était de voir si on arrivait
à créer un système similaire mais qui
arrive également à satisfaire aussi le
quatrième pilier de la loïf
l’apprentissage celui qui lui manquait
jusqu'ici Stuart m'a envoyé quelques
références sur le sujet et j'ai commencé
à travailler dessus on a eu en quelques
mois des résultats vraiment très
chouettes mais ça a pris pas mal de
temps et de publier c'est souvent comme
ça et aujourd'hui on peut donc fièrement
annoncer la sortie de notre article dans
une vraie revue scientifique la
physicale review I et je vais essayer
maintenant de vous expliquer dans les
grandes lignes ce qu'on a fait on va
repartir du système chimique qui avait
étudié initialement Stuart darklet qu'on
appelle le système de Grey Scott je l'ai
pas mal présenté dans ma vidéo sur la
loyf et je vous y renvoie pour les
détails
en gros on considère deux substances
chimiques A et B qui peuvent diffuser
dans un milieu et qui réagissent selon
une certaine réaction d'auto catalyse
deux molécules de B ont la capacité de
transformer une molécule de a en une
autre molécule de B
si on choisit bien les paramètres ce
système qui est un système dit de
réaction diffusion et bien il possède
une propriété assez folle quand on le
stimule on voit des tâches du composé B
qui sont capables de croître de se
diviser et de conquérir l'espace comme
le ferait des cellules et là il faut
bien comprendre qu'il n'y a pas de
cellules pas de membrane ce sont
vraiment juste des tâches d'un composé
chimique le système est incroyablement
simple et Stuart avait notamment montré
que ce système cochait les trois
premiers critères de la définition de la
loyf c'est une structure dissipative
autocataleytique puisqu'elle se
reproduit est capable d'homéostasie
puisque si on la perturbe un peu elle
revient dans son état stationnaire par
contre il y a pas là-dedans le quatrième
pilier l’apprentissage ce système n'a
pas la capacité de mémoriser des choses
sur l'environnement et de les utiliser
pour améliorer sa survie
et c'est ça qu'on a essayé de faire
ensemble en modifiant le système alors
plus précisément on s'est intéressé à
l'idée d'apprentissage par association
c'est une idée assez simple mais qu'on
illustre généralement avec des
organismes vivants complexes l'exemple
typique c'est l'histoire du chien de
Pavlov vous savez un chien salive quand
on lui présente de la nourriture et
maintenant si on sonne une cloche à
chaque fois juste avant de lui donner à
manger et bien au bout d'un moment il
aura mémorisé l'association entre le
stimulus la cloche et l'événement la
nourriture et il se mettra à saliver des
consonnes la cloche même si la
nourriture n'arrive pas après par contre
si on arrête de sonner la cloche pendant
suffisamment longtemps ou qu'on la sonne
sans rapport avec la nourriture et bien
le chien apprendra à force qu'il n'y a
plus de lien entre cloche et nourriture
l'apprentissage par association c'est ça
c'est mémoriser traiter et exploiter
l'existence d'un lien entre un stimulus
et un événement et pour la survie d'une
espèce vivante et bien ça peut jouer un
rôle essentiel prenez l'idée d'échapper
à des prédateurs imaginez une proie
disons une gazelle et son prédateur un
guépard si la Gazelle est capable de
faire le lien entre un stimulus par
exemple un son bizarre ou certains
mouvements dans les herbes et la
présence d'un guépard et bien elle va
pouvoir s'échapper plus rapidement alors
peut-être qu'elle se fera un peu
surprendre au début mais à force de
repérer le même signe annonciateur
chaque fois que le prédateur attaque et
bien elle va apprendre le lien entre les
deux de façon générale le fait de
détecter un stimulus qui annonce une
menace permet de s'en défendre de façon
plus efficace en anticipant en
généralement ce type de capacité
d'apprentissage par association on
l’illustre avec des organismes complexes
possédant un système nerveux
suffisamment développé mais ça n'est pas
spécifique d'espèces comme les
mammifères ni même les animaux en
général on peut avoir de l'apprentissage
par association dans des cas beaucoup
plus simple et c'est ça qu'on a voulu
implémenter dans nos simulations de
petites taches chimiques on a voulu
montrer qu'elles peuvent apprendre des
choses sur leur environnement et les
utiliser pour se défendre de façon
anticipée contre une menace alors voici
comment on a fait on a donc notre
composé chimique B qui représente en
gros notre système auto-calédique et
imaginons qu'il existe une espèce
chimique T qui soit comme une toxine
c'est-à-dire que T réagit avec le
composé B et le détruit et supposons que
la toxine arrive par les bords à
intervalles réguliers d'abord à petite
dose puis de façon de plus en plus
importante
voici ce qui va se passer vous voyez ici
deux cartes de la même région
géographique à gauche on représente la
quantité de B donc on voit nos petites
tâches et à droite on va représenter en
rouge la concentration de toxines T qui
vous le voyez arrive périodiquement par
le bord et diffuse vers le centre et il
y en a de plus en plus à chaque vague et
voyez qu'au fur et à mesure des vagues
d'attaque la toxine se propage et
détruit progressivement le système
bon maintenant on va supposer deux
choses premièrement que chaque attaque
de toxines est précédé peut avant d'un
signe annonciateur sous la forme d'une
vague d'une autre espèce chimique notée
s ce sera notre stimulus l'équivalent du
bruit dans les feuillages pour la
gazelle qui va bientôt se faire attaquer
par le guépard donc ici j'ai ajouté une
autre représentation pour la quantité de
stimulus s en orange et une vague de s
annonce une attaque imminente de toxines
t l'idée c'est de voir comment notre
système peut utiliser cette information
pour se défendre
pour ça on va supposer que notre composé
B à la capacité de catalyser la
production d'un antidote N qui peut
neutraliser la toxine mais on imagine
que pour être efficace cet antidote doit
être largué de façon préventive avant
l'attaque parce que celle-ci est assez
violente on cherche donc à créer un
système chimique qui soit capable de
repérer l'association entre le stimulus
et la toxine de mémoriser l'intensité de
cette association et d'utiliser cette
mémoire pour déclencher la production
d'Antidote de façon préventive pour se
défendre
en revanche si l'environnement évolue
c'est-à-dire si la force de
l'association entre stimulus et toxines
change on veut que le système s'adapte
si l'association disparaît que le
stimulus continue d'arriver mais qu'il
n'y a plus de toxines et bien on veut
que le système arrête de produire et
Nutella de l'antidote ou si au contraire
les attaques de toxines sont de plus en
plus violentes on veut que ce soit
reflété dans les réactions du système et
après pas mal de boulot et des tonnes de
calcul c'est donc cela qu'on a réussi à
faire avec nos simulations concevoir un
système chimique simple capable
d'apprendre par association et cela
d'une façon qui lui permet d'augmenter
ses chances de survie alors voici
comment ça fonctionne dans les grandes
lignes quand le stimulus apparaît il
catalyse la production d'une substance m
qu'on appelle la mémoire à court terme
s'il n'y a pas de toxines après le
stimulus donc s'il n'y a pas
d'associations aiment se dégrade et rien
ne se passe mais si la toxine apparaît à
la suite du stimulus m est convertie en
une autre substance notée elle et qu'on
appelle la mémoire à long terme
celle-ci se dégrade beaucoup plus
lentement et c'est elle qui enregistre
l'existence d'une association entre
stimulus et toxines si une vague de
toxines suit de près une vague de
stimulus alors la concentration de elle
va augmenter et si ce n'est plus le cas
la concentration va diminuer
et donc dernière ingrédient pour que la
défense fonctionne la présence de l
déclenche la production de l'antidote
chaque fois que le stimulus réapparaît
si on a une vague de stimulus en
présence de mémoire à long terme on a
production d'Antidote pour anticiper
l'arrivée imminente de la toxine et avec
ça après pas mal de simulations on a
montré qu'on a bien un système chimique
capable d'apprendre par association et
de déclencher une réponse adéquate qui
permet une défense préventive contre la
toxine sur cette vidéo on voit que le
système se défend produit de l'antidote
qui neutralise en partie la toxine et
limite les dégâts et quand la force de
l'attaque de toxine diminue le système
oublie l'association la mémoire à long
terme se dissipe et il n'y a plus de
production d'Antidote les tâches peuvent
à nouveau se diviser et reconquérir
l'espace perdu
on a donc bien un système capable de
faire de l'apprentissage par association
et on a même montré par des simulations
plus détaillées que la concentration de
l la mémoire à long terme est
numériquement corrélée à la force de
l'association entre stimulus et toxines
on a donc bien cette fois une simulation
d'un système purement chimique et qui
coche les critères de définition de la
Loïse structure dissipative autocats
homéostasie et apprentissage alors
est-ce que ça veut dire qu'on a
artificiellement créé une forme de vie
évidemment non déjà ce qu'on a là c'est
une simulation l'étape suivante ça
consiste à essayer de faire ça sous la
forme d'une vraie expérience avec des
vraies réactifs chimiques et on va
travailler dessus avec des collègues
expérimentateurs ensuite notre système a
quand même une capacité d'apprentissage
limitée ça n'est pas un truc super
robuste qui résiste à tout l'intérêt de
ce travail de recherche ce n'est pas
d'avoir créé un système super
impressionnant c'est de montrer qu'il
est possible de faire des systèmes
chimiques extrêmement simples mais
capable d'apprendre sur leur
environnement pour s'y adapter
ce sont des réactions simples il y a peu
de composés impliqués donc c'est quand
même assez générique l'idée de notre
recherche est donc plutôt de repousser
une limite en montrant que des systèmes
de ce genre sont possibles sans
forcément avoir recours à un arsenal de
réactions chimiques hyper complexe donc
on aurait du mal à comprendre comment
elles auraient pu émerger spontanément
et donc notre système peut constituer un
exemple abstrait de proto-formes de vie
intermédiaire qui pourrait avoir émergé
lors de l'apparition de la vie sur terre
ou qui pourrait émerger ailleurs que sur
Terre avec peut-être des conditions
physico-chimiques très différentes des
nôtres alors une dernière mise en garde
pour finir pour ne pas que vous soyez
victime d'un biais concernant cette
vidéo en généralement sur cette chaîne
je parle de travaux scientifiques que
important ayant passé l'épreuve du temps
ou bien parfois d'actualité mais sur des
sujets scientifiques dont on sait déjà
qui sont des résultats marquants là
c'est pas du tout ça je vous parle de
mon propre travail de recherche et même
si les publier dans une bonne revue que
je suis très content et je trouve qu'on
avait vraiment des très chouettes
résultats je suis pas en train de vous
annoncer une révolution scientifique
comme la plupart des travaux de
recherche c'est vraiment juste une
goutte d'eau mais j'espère qu'elle va
contribuer à son échelle à faire avancer
le sujet mais ça on le saura quand on
aura les réactions des chercheurs de la
communauté qui travaillent sur ces
questions de vie artificielle et des
origines de la vie et voilà c'est tout
pour cette annonce si vous êtes curieux
et vous voulez en savoir plus et bien
vous pouvez aller lire l'article
détaillé je vous mettrai le lien en
description toute proportion gardée il y
a assez peu de pré-requis techniques ce
sont des simulations de cinétique de
réactions chimiques avec des équations
différentielles assez simples voilà
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo un peu
particulière j'espère qu'on continuera
ce travailleur cherche et que j'aurai
d'autres choses chouettes à vous montrer
sur le sujet à l'avenir en attendant je
vous dis à très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos à bientôt
[Musique]